osha announces they will be putting
their unconstitutional vax mandate on
hold as cases spike in heavily
vaccinated states the kyle written house
trial hits another speed bump and
democrats vote to censure a republican
congressman for an anime cartoon i'm
bench bureau this is the bench bureau
show
ben shapiro is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one moment first you know the
reality is that if you have a bunch of
stuff and you are taking it through tsa
why wouldn't you have some sort of
privacy lock on your stuff right you
never know who's looking through your
stuff and why exactly would you be
online without any sort of protection
for your internet activity you know much
information that is valuable you are
passing online from your credit cards to
your emails well you really should
protect that activity with expressvpn
when you go online without a vpn
internet service providers can see every
single website you visit and then they
can legally sell that information
without your consent to add companies
and tech giants who use the data to
target you plus hackers have access to
it if you're using public wi-fi so use
expressvpn to protect yourself the same
way that i do you can browse more
anonymously because when you use
expressvpn isps cannot see your online
activity your identity is anonymized by
a secure vpn server your data is also
encrypted for maximum protection
it's easy to use you can fire up the app
click one button and now you are
protected and it works on all your
devices so secure your online activity
the same way i do visit expressvpn.com
ben today that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn dot
com slash you get an extra three months
for free expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so yesterday osha suspended
its vax mandate they did so because the
fifth circuit court of appeals had
essentially
put a hold on it they said that there
were serious constitutional and
statutory issues with the osha vaccine
mandate you'll remember that that
mandate was set to kick into place at
the beginning of january and it said
that if you had over 100 employees you
had to force your employees to vac test
or be fired that was the mandate and we
at the daily wire we filed maybe the
first case first lawsuit against it in
the nation certainly the first lawsuit
at the sixth circuit court of appeals
well now there are cases right now in
all 12 circuits those are going to be
consolidated and sent over to the sixth
circuit after there was a little bit of
a lottery they actually used lottery
balls to pick which circuit would get to
consolidate the cases were in the sixth
circuit court of appeals that's our case
which means that the daily wire is now
leading the case for the nation
against osha now the hole that's been
put on is a victory for the moment
when i say for the moment i mean that
the biden administration says that they
will continue to force the osha vax
mandate the minute that a court says
that it's okay for them to do so
however this that's why this is the
first step that's why it's important to
help support us here at daily wire in
pushing back against the vaccine mandate
because this will be adjudicated by a
panel for the sixth circuit court of
appeals then it will likely be appealed
over to the supreme court so this is
just the beginning of the battle and we
are calling on all other businesses to
do what we have done so we at daily wire
said day one we would not comply with
this unconstitutional vaccine mandate we
are not going to do it from the get-go
and a lot of businesses they said well
you know maybe you can afford that or
maybe you're willing to undertake that
risk but we are not because obviously
the federal government can come after us
so we will attempt to comply with the
vax mandate even though it has not yet
gone fully into force well now it's not
in force at all and so if you're a
freedom-minded business do not make it
easy for the federal government by doing
what the federal government wants you to
do instead stand up for the freedom of
your employees that is what we've done
at daily wire that's what we're pushing
everybody to do head on over to
dailywire.com right now and sign our
petition the way that it works is that
osha has a
hearing period for all of their
regulations not the emergency temporary
standards they're trying to use here but
their actual regulatory standards and so
we hope to submit to them a million
signatures
in support of the idea that this vast
mandate is a bad idea through the
regulatory process so you can go help us
out right now doing that well here's the
thing as
time moves forward and as we see how the
how the dax mandates are playing out
across the nation what we are seeing
is that infections are still spiking in
heavily vaccinated states this is not a
case against the vaccine as i've said
before the vaccine is very good at
preventing hospitalization and death
which is typically what we care about
the problem is that for the left-leaning
media for the democrats
they have boxed themselves in they have
suggested that the only way to end the
pandemic is if no one gets infected
that's never going to happen
and what really should end the pandemic
is the fact that vaccines were available
now you could protect yourself within
the next month we're going to have
therapeutics that are as protective as
the vaccine in some cases according to
the new studies that are coming out
right there's a therapeutic from pfizer
it's a pill that if you take it within a
couple of days of being diagnosed with
covid it knocks out the death rates to
zero
okay so with all that in play
this is over okay we are done now there
should be no public policy push with
regard to any of this stuff once people
can protect themselves if you choose not
to be protected that is you problem and
if you are protected what everybody else
does is none of your business at this
point because we are not reaching herd
immunity everybody understands we are
not reaching herd immunity when herd
immunity was in sight when there was an
idea that if we got 80 of the population
vast that would end all infections
because the r would drop before below
one and then no one would be passing
this thing on
then at least you had the argument but
herd immunity is not a thing it is not a
thing with this virus and this is going
to become endemic everybody understands
that endemic just means that it is going
to continue passing through the
population for long periods of time and
you can see it in state after state
after state
right now for example michigan has the
most coveted cases in the nation
michigan also is one of the more
vaccinated states in the nation
according to the latest data michigan
has over 50 000 new coveted cases in the
past week that comes out to 503.8 cases
per 100 000.
minnesota is second with 490 cases new
mexico has 462 cases
so um
you you will notice there that all three
of those states are blue
we were told that only red states get
covered because red states are evil but
that's not the case
the last time michigan led the nation
was in april when the state encountered
the largest surge of the coven 19
pandemic and we know why this is
happening the answer is this is
happening because people are going
indoors because it's getting cold in
michigan
it's that simple
in the past three weeks henry ford
health system says its hospital system
has seen a 60 rise in the number of
patients hospitalized with covid
according to one of the doctors over
there they have 330 patients with covet
hospitalized across five hospitals
another 35 patients with covet or
suspected covid
apparently most of those hospitalized
with covenant 19 are not vaccinated
okay well
that i'm sure is true because you're
much more likely to be hospitalized with
covet if you're unvaccinated by the
statistics what that does not mean is
that you cannot pass this thing on if
you are vaccinated to other people who
are vaccinated
right now what we have seen is that the
vaccines are not particularly durable in
terms of preventing re-infection
they're durable in preventing
hospitalization and death
and now it is up to you it is up to you
and none of the people on the left seem
to want to recognize this so what is the
point of the osha vaccine mandate
if the idea of the ocean vaccine mandate
is we have to prevent this thing from
being passed
well the vaccine itself does not prevent
in total all of this virus from being
passed
there's a somewhat lower rate of passing
the virus if you are vaccinated versus
if you are unvaccinated
but it is not a completely lower rate
which is why you would see outbreaks in
heavily vaccinated areas for example
ireland right now
is a 93 vast country it reimposed
coveted restrictions anyway because
there is a massive uptick in the number
of coveted cases there's a member of the
health service explaining that
as a society we need to look out for
each other 93
of the adult population are fully
vaccinated
we have over 600 people in hospital at
the moment and roughly around half of
those are unvaccinated
the evidence is absolutely clear and
tonight i would join with all of our
healthcare professionals in urging
people who have not yet received the
vaccine to please take it up
now again urging people to take the
vaccine is not a terrible thing forcing
people to take the vaccine is a very
different thing you're seeing the same
thing in vermont by the way vermont has
the highest vaccination rate in the
country and cases are surging over there
according to abc news in vermont nearly
72 percent of residents are fully
vaccinated against covet 19. at the same
time it has the 12th highest rate of new
covet cases over the last week according
to state data and in the country right
now we have a major surge in covet cases
now i don't care about covet cases you
shouldn't care about covert cases you
should only care about hospitalizations
and deaths and at this point you should
really only care about whether you and
your family are protected and whether
your neighbors are protected and whether
they also have the freedom to determine
whether they are protected and those are
the factors you do not get to tell your
neighbor how to protect themselves you
do get to protect yourself how you wish
to protect yourself and yet we still
have the binding administration
attempting to cram down these mandates
the seven day average for coven 19 cases
rose 42 as of tuesday according to state
data in vermont
and the state positivity rate also
increased 30 percent
so what we are seeing is that even
heavily vaccinated areas are still
seeing a pretty significant uptick in
covid by the way you know where they are
having very few covet cases down here in
florida why because it already passed
through the population and it's nice
outside this is not complicated
the lowest state in terms of current
case casey average
over the last seven days
florida georgia louisiana texas that is
not a coincidence all four of those
states got clocked over the summer in
terms of number of people who are
getting this was very hot outside people
going indoors
some people were getting re-infected
some people who are unvaccinated were
dying
but right now which states are getting
clocked
it's minnesota wisconsin michigan new
hampshire vermont yes new york
pennsylvania ohio basically anywhere it
is cold anywhere people are going
indoors this is not a shock
and yet the the biden administration
continues to push forward with this
notion that they're going to mandate
on you
and on your employer that you get the
facts
here's the thing democrats are in a
tailspin right now and they don't know
which way to turn
because one thing they do understand is
that americans are very tired of this
how tired are americans with this
they're so tired that in washington dc
which is bluer than blue
in washington dc is the bluest area in
america
muriel bowser the mayor just came out
and said she's going to get rid of the
masking mandates
at
local stores why because business owners
who are going to contribute to her
mayoral campaign said we're not going to
contribute unless you allow us to do our
business
and of course you have other democrats
who are attacking mayor bowser now so
you have the head of the dc city council
phil mendelson writing a letter to
muriel bowser
saying that they want to reinstate the
mass mandate
they say we even the white house will
maintain its mass mandate we urge you to
reverse your decision to drop the mass
mandate
we are concerned that changing course
entering the winter months not to
mention the week before a major travel
holiday is not a pruding course of
action it sends a signal that public
health concerns are back to normal when
they are not our focus should be on
getting every eligible person vaccinated
not gambling with the safety of the most
vulnerable et cetera et cetera et cetera
so democrats are stuck between a rock
and a hard place and here is the thing
there are significant costs to the
lockdown policies that have been
attempted by blue states and blue cities
and one statistic that might be worth
noting is we've had about 700 thousand
deaths from covert over the course of
the last year and over the course of the
last year more than 100 000 americans
died from drug overdoses
a hundred thousand that is from april of
last year to april of this year
according to the new york times in that
12-month period more than a hundred
thousand americans died of overdoses up
almost 30 percent from the 78 000 deaths
in the prior year that figure marks the
first time the number of overdose deaths
in the us has exceeded 100 000 per year
more than the total of car crashes and
gun fatalities combined
overdose deaths have more than doubled
since 2015.
by the way this does give the lies in
the notion that more government aid
prevents overdose deaths we had more
government aid in the last year than any
time in american history bar none
and overdose death spiked why because
when you destroy people's sense of
community their ability to reach out to
other human beings they stay home and
they get high and they do drugs and many
of them die
administration officials said on
wednesday they will expand access to
medications like like naloxone which can
reverse an opioid overdose by
encouraging states to pass laws that
will make it more widely available and
promoting its use by americans
but the the coveted pandemic accelerated
this and really the response to the
covert pandemic accelerated this
overdose deaths related to use of
stimulants like meth coke and natural
and semi-synthetic opioids also
increased during the 12-month period so
it's not just fentanyl here
the vast majority of those deaths 70
were among men between the age of 25 and
54.
there were regional variations in the
death count but the largest
year-over-year increase is exceeding 50
in states including california
vermont increased 85 during the
reporting period
you saw some poorer areas like tennessee
louisiana mississippi west virginia
kentucky that had a pretty major uptick
as well
but you also saw increases of 40
in washington state oregon nevada
colorado minnesota alaska nebraska
virginia and the carolinas
okay so
it turns out that
shutting down the entire country has
some pretty dire side effects
and americans know this and democrats
are about to pay the political price for
all of this
which is why governor ron desantis has
not been doing this the whole time
governor desantis in florida
he just pushed through a bunch of
anti-mass mandates and vax mandate
proposals in the state of florida
according to the new york times
early this year governor ron desantis
criss-crossed florida promoting coveted
vaccines visiting retiree communities in
hospitals celebrating people who got
their shots but it was a remarkably
different picture this week when
florida's lieutenant governor jeannette
nunes was a prominent speaker at a rally
organized by anti-vax activists on the
state capitol steps
well
no
she she was there not fighting in the
vags she's there fighting vax mandates
full disclosure i'm very friendly with
both governor desantis and jeannette
nunez who's a wonderful lieutenant
governor
but says the new york times the jarring
scene gave vaccine skeptics in florida a
big win and moved the state further away
from the guidance of federal public
officials perhaps no state has been more
aggressive than florida where mr
desantis and his allies are betting that
anger over public health restrictions
that drove republicans to the polls in
virginia new jersey and other states
will grow their political base and keep
voters fervently engaged
the republicans passed four bills on
wednesday to curtail mask and vax
mandates the culmination of a three-day
special legislative session that mr
desantis called so swiftly it caught
even republican leaders by surprise the
session was urgently needed to combat
federal government overreach said
santa's which of course is true the
federal government is mandating that
businesses do what the federal
government wants them to do the state of
florida is saying well no we're just
going to fight back against that and now
we're not going to allow you to do what
the federal government is telling you to
do creating a conflict of law situation
that frees businesses to do essentially
what they want
and the this is i love how the new york
times proposes that
this is all about being anti-vaxxed in
florida if you look at the vaccination
rates by state in america florida is
right in the middle of the
pack this is this bizarre idiotic notion
that florida is somehow like on the low
end of vaccine vaccination rates is
totally crazy it's not true
i'm looking right now at the
at the rate of full vaccination
by state
okay and let's look at age 65 let's
start with age 65. if you look at the
percentage of people who are vaccinated
above the age of 65
florida has
93.2 is going to mayo clinic
93.2
of all people in florida above the age
of 65 is a really old state by the way
are vaccinated
of people aged 18 to 64 almost 70 are
vaccinated 67.1 percent are vaccinated
by the way those are better numbers than
a huge number of blue states including
by the way michigan
even among people 12 to 17 almost 50
percent of florida residents age 12 to
17 are fully vaccinated
and if you look at the numbers on one
dose vaccinations if you look at the
number of people who have gotten at
least one dose you're looking at 99.9
of all people aged over 65 have one dose
of the vaccine in florida and 78 of
floridians between 18 and 64 have the
vaccine so you're seeing the media
trying to proclaim that this is all
about how florida doesn't want people
the vets to lie it's just not true
because they are damned liars flora just
would like you to retain your freedoms
and we here at the daily wire would also
like you to retain your freedom so
please go sign our petition over at
dailywire.com because we are fighting
back against this garbage
and you should be too
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the latest in the kyle rittenhouse
trial which once again is going sideways
major boo-boo by the prosecution we'll
get to that in just one second first
we'd love to welcome some friends and
sponsors back to the show just in time
for the holidays we're talking about
vincero collective if you don't know
ventura yet they're a small team based
out of san diego they provide today's
most ambitious people with premium
watches and lifestyle accessories
they've got eye-catching designs quality
craftsmanship you can feel in your hand
they've got incredible pieces sure to
become staples in your wardrobe and
beyond so i'm a watch guy right i love
watches but if you're not going to spend
10 grand for a watch and you just want a
really nice looking watch vincero is the
place to go like look at this this is a
really nice looking timepiece it really
is a great looking timepiece and it's
really durable i've gotten vincero as
gifts for friends and family for years i
just got my wife some ventura sunglasses
as well no matter who you are shopping
for vincero has a collection and
colorway for everyone making it easy to
find a great gift for that special
someone so don't wait now is the time to
take advantage of ventura's black friday
sale it is their biggest of the year
head on over to vincerocollective.com
shapiro check out our favorite picks
take advantage of their exclusive black
friday sale here at the daily wire we
stand firmly behind ventura collective
the products they sell brand they've
built values they stand for you don't
need to take my word for it with over
thirty thousand five star reviews
ventura offers you an excellent shopping
experience you can trust and they've got
a five-year guarantee and 365-day free
return policy so you really have nothing
to lose support our show do yourself a
favor check out vincero collective
you're gonna be super happy once you do
even better for a limited time you can
take advantage of up to 30 off all items
in your order plus free shipping as part
of their black friday sale
it's the perfect opportunity to get
yourself or a loved one a gift they
won't forget go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
collective dot com forward slash shapiro
vincero collective dot com forward slash
shapiro and thank me later alrighty so
the written house trial continues to
undergo deliberation it is insane to me
that we are still deliberating about
this case i say we i mean the jury this
case is the most clear-cut case of
self-defense i've ever seen in my life
but
they're the the judge yesterday
correctly blasted the media for their
misinformation about the trial here's
what the judge had to say
some of the other misinformation about
the case that is widespread
and you gentlemen are as aware of it as
i am
now they had some people
in the milwaukee journal i i think i
read it said it was
odd i think was the word that
i didn't gruel on the motion to dismiss
i haven't even had a chance to read the
motion to dismiss i just got it
yesterday
and i really think before i rule on
emotion
i should let the state respond
so why anyone would think that it's odd
for the judge to sit on a motion to
dismiss i have no idea
okay so the media coverage in the case
has been absolutely bizarre he is
exactly right about that and politically
driven well yesterday the prosecution
ran directly into a buzz saw because it
turns out that the prosecution handed
over a badly pixelated version of the
drone footage remember there was drone
footage of the of the first shooting of
joseph rosenbaum by kyle rittenhouse and
it turns out that the prosecution had
that for a long time and finally when
they turned it over it was a badly
pixelated version of the video according
to breitbart the dispute involved
several videos especially a high
definition video the prosecution used in
closing arguments on friday which had
not been provided to the defense which
received only a low-res version the
defense moved for a mistrial tuesday on
that basis
ada john krause told the judge the
prosecution had not intentionally
withheld video evidence from the defense
but there was an accidental compression
involved in moving video between iphone
and android devices
the person who took the footage
according to kraus had earlier provided
it to rittenhouse's former attorney john
pierce who had shown it last year on the
tucker carlson show on fox news when it
was emailed to the defense there was a
compression he said which had not been
deliberate he said um he had no idea how
to compress the files the defense
countered the files appeared to be
different and the metadata accompanying
the video appeared different
the defense also said the video provided
to tucker carlson was different as it
was black and white the prosecutor's
video was in color that had not been the
problem but rather the superior quality
of the prosecution's video
defense lawyer mark richard said at this
point your honor they've not requested
what we're fighting about you're correct
the judge replied
earlier on wednesday the jury did send a
question to the judge about whether it
would be permitted to review video
evidence in the courtroom or in private
so that came in late yesterday afternoon
okay so
the prosecutors
tried to claim that it was just a
technical glitch the defense said that
this video evidence was compressed by
the prosecution and passed over to them
in order to deceive them which wouldn't
be a shock because there have been
serious evidentiary questions throughout
here is a the defense making that
argument
the one that was provided to the state's
crime lab that attorney finger gave me a
copy of on saturday had a very long
convoluted title that involves lots of
letters and numbers that are
the type that are usually associated
with files taken from a drone because
they indicate a lot of different
information like the location of the
drone and the time
the file i received originally on friday
the fifth
was
not labeled that same and was not the
same file amount
there's no way that what ada krause is
saying is true because
the file name would not have changed if
my computer was compressing anything it
was a different file that we were
provided from what was provided to the
state at least for what attorney binger
gave me on saturday they're completely
different
okay meanwhile the prosecution admitted
there was a technical glitch but they
said it was just a technical glitch no
biggie the defense by the way is arguing
that one of the reasons the prosecution
did this is because they were looking
for a mistrial because this is going so
badly for them
i think we're focusing on
too heavily on
i guess a technological glitch and less
on the and we should be focusing that
this exhibit was played the jury is
asking to see in exhibits that they have
seen they didn't know about this video
they tried to find it just as we did
we found it and there was a
technological glitch
or not a glitch but i guess
it worked in a way that is designed that
we were not aware of and i do not
believe
a
technical reality shall we say or a
technical an unknown
technical incident
should result in a mistrial
yeah um
yeah sure okay meanwhile the media
continue their habit of drawing the most
bizarre narratives out of this case
farhad manju who somehow has finagled a
column at the new york times which is
amazing because truly is there is a
running battle between the members of
the new york times editorial board about
which one of them is the worst columnist
farhad manager is definitely near the
top of the list i think it goes like
charles blow paul krugman farhad manager
but he's climbing the list each and
every day uh he had a piece yesterday in
which he argued that the the big problem
in the kyle rittenhouse case was the gun
not the people rioting in the streets
attacking the guy with a gun the gun
according to firehead manju the lead
prosecutor thomas binger offered a
meticulously documented closing argument
that deftly summarized all the ways
written house acted unlawfully we'll see
if the jury buys it but to me bingo's
argument had a power beyond this case
that's because it cleverly unraveled
some of the foundational tenets of gun
advocacy that guns are effective and
necessary weapons of self-defense well
i'm not sure how that was unraveled
considering that
rittenhouse would probably be dead today
or at the very least in a coma hospital
if um if he had not had a gun he says
that without them lawlessness and
tyranny would prevail wallace's and
tyranny did prevail in kenosha wisconsin
and that in the right hands in the hands
of the good guys guns promote public
safety rather than destroying it
well i mean they do there just weren't
enough guns there in the hands of the
good guys there was one good guy with
gun kyle rittenhouse in this particular
case up against an entire riotous mob
one of whom was a child molester trying
to attack him another of whom was a
convicted criminal who was trying to
attack him with a skateboard and a third
of whom was approaching him with his own
gun
but says firehead manju in the written
house case none of that was true at
every turn that night ridden house's
ar-15 style semi-automatic rifle made
things worse ratcheting up danger rather
than quelling it the gun transformed
situations that might have ended in
black eyes and broken bones into ones
that ended with corpses in the street
well whose fault is that the people
attacking the guy with the gun or the
guy with god
but you know the left must have its
narratives so we'll continue to keep an
eye on the jury in that particular case
honestly i'm shocked they still have not
come back in at this point okay
meanwhile
the other big controversy of the day
that broke out yesterday was a
controversy over paul gosar paul gosar
is the rather nutty congress person from
arizona who is hobnobbed with some of
the worst derelicts uh on the on the
political ultra right
you know this sort of
white supremacist adjacent crowd like
paul gosar has hung out with some pretty
bad folks i am no paul gosar fan but
the house attempting to censure gosar
for what they're attempting to censor
him for
is pretty wild and what's more wild is
that they attempted to strip him of his
community assignments and they did
yesterday a democratic house has now
been stripping republicans of their
committee assignments which is a pretty
big violation of the way that this stuff
usually works we'll get to that in just
a moment first i got to tell you about
one of the best gifts i ever got my
parents so my parents out in their
garage for years just had boxes of old
film reels boxes of old pictures boxes
of old vhs tapes of us as kids and just
sitting there doing nothing and so i
went over to their house to their garage
and i took all that stuff i loaded it up
into a legacy box i sent it into legacy
box and legacy box returned all of that
material along with the digitization of
all of that old footage all those old
film reels etc it's great they can
access it they make copies of it for the
entire family and it really is wonderful
to be able to access those memories at
any point in time and also know that if
god forbid the garage floods those
memories aren't gone they're right there
on a thumb drive and that's what legacy
box can do for you each item is hand
digitized by a team of over 200 train
technicians right here in the us their
exclusive barcoded online tracking
system provides up to 12 emailed updates
along the way legacy box has been the
industry leader in professionally
digitizing family members for over a
decade more than a million people have
used them
each kit includes everything you need to
safely pack and send your recorded
moments legacy box right now is giving
our listeners early access to their
black friday sale visit
legacybox.com to unlock an exclusive
discount for our black friday sale that
is legacybox.com shapiro for their best
deal of the year legacybox.com
shapiro okay so
now we move to congress where as always
idiocy reigns so paul gosar as i've said
is uh
not a good congress person he is a uh he
is a rather nutty character to say the
absolute least
he put out on twitter
an anime video
okay this anime video has now become
subject to controversy because it was
taken as an actual death threat against
alexander ocasio-cortez here's the anime
video
[Music]
okay so it's just images of people at
the border and then an anime character
flying through the air
and um
and then
people riding atvs near the border and
helicopters near the border
and the anime video shows this this paul
gosar anime character attacking with
swords a figure
which appears to be like a half-naked
male with uh with the face of alexandra
ocasio-cortez and then jumping toward
the face of joe biden with anime swords
that this is what they're talking about
okay can i just say
that anybody who takes this is an actual
death threat against aoc is out of their
mind
i'm sorry you're crazy if you think
that's an actual death threat against
aoc you're a crazy person as somebody
who's received their fair share of death
threats i can safely say
that in no way would i see something
like this and think oh that's that's a
legit death threat that's somebody who's
trying to kill me
i could say
yeah i'm offended it's really stupid
it's literally an anime meme video and
gosar is he's like an
somewhat elderly dude who likes to hang
out with the meme crowd
like the alt-right meme crowd
and um and yet this was taken as a as an
actual death threat against alexander
ocasio-cortez and joe biden
which is wild okay it's it's kind of an
insane thing
so here is a paul gosar defending
himself again he is a wild dude
for this cartoon some in congress
suggest i should be punished i have said
decisively there is no threat in the
cartoon other than the threat to the
immigration poses to our country
and no threat was intended by my staff
or me
the american people deserve to have
their voices heard in congress
no matter how much the left tries to
quiet me i will continue to speak out
against amnesty for illegal aliens if i
must join alexander hamilton the first
person attempted to be censored by this
house
so be it it is done
okay so
is he a hero for tweeting it out no is
it a stupid meme yes but here is the
thing the entire democratic party
responds to this as though he has
actively threatened aoc's life so you
get nancy pelosi out there blasting
gosar and saying we can't have members
joking about murdering each other
or this is this is where you draw the
line like i'm the anime video that
that's that's this is what you're gonna
blow up congress over okay nancy sure
these threats specifically target a
woman a woman of color which is part as
the resolution states a global
phenomenon meant to silence women and
discourage them for seeking positions of
authority and participating
in public life disguising death threats
against a member of congress and a
president of the united states is an ant
in an animated video does not make those
death threats any less real or less
serious that's absurd she's an absurd
human being conveying them this way
makes them potentially more dangerous by
normalizing it's more dangerous
she's a crazy person i'm sorry she's
crazy like first of all did secret
service investigate paul gosar over that
did secret service investigate paul
gosar were they like man that's a
serious death threat let's get our we
gotta get the group together and go raid
his house
making an anime video is more serious
and the suggestion is that he's
attacking aoc because she's a woman of
color that is joe biden a woman of color
you don't have to explain that one maybe
the reason he's attacking aoc like is a
politician again i think the video is
stupid i think members of congress
shouldn't be
putting that stuff out but let's stop
pretending that that is like a full
death threat come the f come on come on
again as a recipient of actual death
threats i can tell you nope that one
ain't even the ballpark
and there's this bizarre crazy idea that
that it's about aoc's race and sex is
again nuts the reason presumably that
he's angry with aoc is because she is an
amnesty first crazy person who has been
treated as the the light of the left
she's very famous the left has made her
famous they're the ones who propped her
up this is the game the left always
plays you can't attack common hare she's
a black woman well you're the ones who
put her in a position of prominence
because of who she is
you're like what it's so weird okay so
then aoc gets up and she does the the
woe is me routine and now aoc is gonna
lecture us about the nature of of
rhetoric in politics aoc because she's
never used inflammatory rhetoric at all
i mean she's one of the most eloquent
well-spoken soft-spoken subtle artists
in the rhetorical space aoc
it is sad
it is a sad day
in which a member who leads a political
party in the united states of america
cannot bring
themselves to say
that issuing a depiction of murdering a
member of congress is wrong
and instead
decides to venture off into a tangent
about gas prices and inflation
what is so hard
about saying that this is wrong
okay so this is coming from the same
group of people she voted literally in
favor of not funding iron dome which
helps hamas so yeah or actually she
actually abstained and then she cried
about it on the house floor
yeah she's yeah aoc
i i think do you think this is real i
just have a question you think this is
real i usually don't doubt the sincerity
of political actors talking about how
hurt they are but um as somebody again
who's received more death threats than
virtually anybody in american public
life i can tell you no no on that that
is completely insincere it is a jinned
up nonsense she said
i have seen the other members of this
party advance the argument including
representative gosar himself the
illusion that this was just a joke
the illusion it's an anime video i'm
confused how is that not a joke
have you ever like thrown out an anime
video as a very serious point in a
debate
like in a budget debate do people
normally just throw out anime videos of
themselves
badly pixelated their faces onto anime
characters
the illusion that this was just a joke i
love when they pretend they don't
understand jokes that what we say and
what we do does not matter so long as we
claim a lack of meaning now this
nihilism runs deep says aoc it conveys
and betrays a certain contempt for the
meaning and importance of our work here
okay let me not betray um a a lack of
contempt for i i have contempt for the
meaning of your work here all of you all
of you in congress i think that you're
basically useless i think you do nothing
for a living and get paid on the tax
paradigm and then claim that you're
changing the world
while wrecking america's fiscal future
so let me just put that one out there
but it betrays contempt for the meaning
of the work that we do here that's what
we do so long as we claim it's a joke it
doesn't matter that's what we say that
what we say here doesn't matter that our
actions every day's elected leaders
don't matter and i am here to rise to
say it does she say our work here
matters our example matters there's
meaning in our service
vomit
come on you don't have to like paul
gosar or or even like that he tweeted
out a dumb meme to understand it's not a
death threat that violates the sanctity
of the united states congress
and these people are so irritating
you're making me defend paul gosar now
what the f wrong with you people
seriously what
okay so
peter mayer
who is a congressperson from michigan he
said as someone who has faced death
threats and had a senior party official
reference my assassination i take
political violence seriously
representative gosar disgraced himself
with his actions leading up to january
6th he's disgraced himself further by
associating with anti-semites and
holocaust deniers sadly disgracing
oneself with anti-jewish associates
isn't a rare occurrence for a handful of
my colleagues on either side of the
aisle but today's vote wasn't about
these actions it was about a dumb anime
clip the last century of a member of
congress was in 2010. today democratic
leadership did not present an objective
articulate standard for censure in the
absence of an ethics committee ruling or
a formal legal action
representative gostar's conduct has been
contemptible and calling that video a
death threat is an unreasonable
exaggeration that ignores why political
violence is such a threat leaders
embracing authoritarian lies the
american people deserve a congress that
functions according to reason not
emotion
correct
but we have to pretend to be deeply
offended by by gosar's anime video
i'm offended by you being offended
honest to god sack up
okay meanwhile
you know like when it comes to center
first of all
half of congress had been censured by
this point but what the democrats did is
they removed gosar's committee
assignments now i think there's a good
case that gosar shouldn't have committee
assignments but that has to come from
inside the republican caucus that
doesn't come from the democratic caucus
there's a basic rule republicans name
republican members of committees and
democrats named democrat members of
committees it's been broken now
democrats have said that they will throw
people like marjory taylor green off
committees so get ready for the to reap
the whirlwind here's kevin mccarthy
saying listen you guys want to play this
game next time we're in power we are
going to dump all you guys from your
committee assignments
what they have started cannot be easily
undone
their actions today in the past have
forever changed the way the house
operates
it means that the minority rights that
have served this body as well are the
things of the past
and furthermore it means that under the
pelosi president
all the members that i have mentioned
earlier will need the approval of a
majority to keep those positions in the
future
okay and one he's right in one second
we're gonna get to uh lauren bobert who
honestly like lauren bobert just went
hard after other members of congress and
i'm here for it i'm really here for
we'll get to that in just a moment first
if you're a homeowner who's been focused
on your budget focus on your future
focused on finding the right option to
save money i have something for you to
consider a mortgage refinance it's a
strategic approach it makes a lot of
sense for a lot of people since rates
remain near all-time lows making it a
great time to call american financing
learn about custom loan options that can
save you up to a thousand bucks a month
that's right every month
they do more than just lower your rate
they look at your entire financial
picture finding every way to help you
save no pressure no obligation no
upfront or hidden fees so why not learn
more they'll give you a free mortgage
review you might skip two payments if
you choose to move forward so right now
the mortgage rates are at serious
historic lows i don't think they're
going to stay that way forever i think
mortgage rates are going to rise in the
near future because
frankly inflation is going to force a
tapering at the fed that that tapering
at the fed is going to force banks to
give loans at higher rates and that's
going to force up the mortgage rates so
if you want like a low mortgage rate for
your refi now is the best time
pre-qualify for free by calling eight
six six seven two one thirty three
hundred that's eight six six seven two
one thirty three hundred or visit
americanfinancing.net and mls one eight
two three three four nmls
consumeraccess.org go check them out
right now alrighty in just one second
we'll get to lauren bobert going hard
after other members of congress and
honest to god
slow clap we'll get to that in a moment
first big news the bite administration
announced yesterday it is suspending the
implementation and enforcement of their
authoritarian mandate for large
employers daily wire was first in the
nation of file suit we couldn't be
happier to be at the forefront of the
fight against biden's assault on our
businesses our bodies and our private
health decisions however there are a lot
of businesses will continue enforcing
mandates our victory means nothing
unless those businesses do the right
thing they need to stop we understand
listen we get it we know that federal
rules federal threats are an attempt to
make you comply but those rules are not
in place right now do not make the
government's job easy if you're an
employee your company should not force
you to take a vaccine you don't want
don't let them hide behind the vaccine
mandate because it ain't in place
unless we lose no one has to comply and
we're not going to lose the fight is
just getting started and we are going to
win so sign our petition against biden's
vaccine mandate over at dailywire.com do
not comply to send a message to the
biden administration that americans
don't just do whatever you tell them to
do over 600 000 people have already
signed the petition the more signatures
we get the louder the message that's why
we're aiming to get to a million
signatures we want to submit that to
osha during their hearing period for
their new regulations head on over to
dailywire.com
do not comply to sign the petition today
also if you haven't yet signed up to
matt walsh's newsletter i highly suggest
you do not only will you be getting a
piece of matt's mind delivered to your
inbox every friday you'll be
automatically entered into the running
for his beloved banjo as you all know
matt is just a banjo expert he probably
admired it once or twice on his show
that's right the instrument belonging to
a very real banjo-picking legend could
be yours hurry because if you don't sign
up by saturday the incredibly lucky
winner who gets max banjo will not be
you head on over to dailywire.com banjo
to subscribe to matt's newsletter it's
always full of the best writing besides
my own and get entered to win his
gorgeous banjo you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so lauren bobert the
congresswoman from colorado she was
having none of this she got up on the
floor of the house and she's like okay
so let me get this straight paul gosar
got censored not for any of the
anti-semitic hangings out or any of his
prior bizarre statements but for an
anime meme
and um should we sum up what some
members of this congress have done wrong
lauren bobert just bringing the hammer
good for her i mean honestly
since the speaker has designated the
floor to discuss members inappropriate
actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising
terrorists
and then the cherry on top
my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy let
me say that again a member of congress
who receives classifieds
sleeping with the enemy this is
unacceptable and this would never be his
time to expire gentlemen from florida
um
winner winner chicken dinner lauren
bobert uh points to lauren bobert right
there uh
yup
see here's the thing guys either no one
gets censured or everybody gets injured
that's the way that this has to work
because here's the thing she's correct
congress is full of derelicts congress
is full of people who not only say
terrible things but do terrible things
it is rather incredible that eric
swallower retains his committee
assignments despite the fact that he was
screwing a chinese spy that is kind of
an amazing thing
meanwhile ilhan omar got very upset with
lauren bobert
for for mentioning not her brother
husband the other one
and she tweeted luckily my dad raised me
right otherwise i might have gone to the
floor to talk about this insurrectionist
who sleeps with a pervert i what i like
there is where she flatters herself that
her dad raised her right otherwise i
might have said this thing that i'm
saying right now in a tweet
i am grateful i was raised to be a
decent human that is not
true and not a deprived person who
shamefully defecates and defiles the
house of representatives you can't
defecate the house of representative you
can defecate on the house of
representatives
praise god
so
first of all uh the the thing that she's
referencing there sleeps with a pervert
is that her husband not
not beaubert did anything wrong her
husband was arrested for like uh an
indecent exposure a couple of years ago
but ilhan omar getting into family
issues is real awkward like real awkward
she's got a follow the house of usher
thing going on in her own family
and uh and not just that even if you put
aside the as lauren calls it the alleged
brother husband uh you will have to
recall that she also did in fact pay a
couple of million bucks to her current
husband's firm she was allegedly having
an affair with her current husband while
she was married with the last husband
she does have kids
she's a disaster of a human also she is
just a terrible jew-hating anti-semite
who has never been i mean they they
thought about censuring her they thought
about at least saying something in
congress about her and the democrats
like no we'll just pass a resolution
saying that all forms of hate are bad
by the way johanna omar still has no
answer to the charges of anti-semitism
she's asked by chris hayes about the
jewish community and she's like i'm just
not going to answer this
obviously you have a lot of jewish folks
in your district you have a lot of
synagogues you have it's a very vibrant
jewish world in the twin cities what
those relationships are like what those
conversations have been like because i
do know people that
have pretty progressive politics that i
do think um have been offended or have
questioned uh your your heart on these
matters and i know that's happened in
your district i'm curious what those
conversations have been like yeah i mean
i i think communities are not monolithic
you know there's different ideologies
people have there's different
perspectives and different places um
where where people come from and there
are different relationships people have
with me that sort of inform a positive
reaction to anything i say or a negative
reaction to anything that i say i'm just
gonna sidestep that you hitting
anti-semitism right there by the way the
democratic party the democratic party
still has received talib as a member of
good standing there's a person who
hobnobs with pro-terror advocates openly
and joe biden was praising her yesterday
like not a year ago yesterday
it's a spare me the crocodile tears on
the oh my god paul gosar put out an
anime meme
it's all just posturing it's uh you want
to know why people hate politics because
we all know that all these people are
full of absolutely extraordinarily toxic
levels of crap they're all septic at
this point
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matte wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show